[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález ya se cumple
un mes de las elecciones presidenciales
en belarús desde entonces este país del
este de europa ha estado inmerso en un
espiral de protestas ciudadanas todo
esto en rechazo a los resultados de sus
comicios presidenciales que ha dado paso
a más censura en los medios de
comunicación represión policial arresto
y escape de algunos de los líderes de la
oposición el despliegue de los servicios
secretos y un presidente que está
aferrado al poder todo esto son
ingredientes perfectos para tener
inestabilidad una inestabilidad que ha
llevado a la unión europea y sobre todo
a rusia a estar muy atentos a lo que
está sucediendo en este país del este de
europa los actores principales de esta
historia se los explico a continuación
para tener un poco de contexto de
quienes están enfrentando allí hay tres
mujeres en la oposición ellas son maría
carles nico va ella es la única que
permanece en este momento en territorio
de belarús haciendo frente a la
persecución por parte del gobierno
svetlana tijuana busca ya ella fue
candidata
comicios en las pasadas elecciones y se
vio obligada a exiliarse en la vecina
lituania por amenazas también esta
verónica se caló ella también tuvo que
dejar el país se unió a su esposo que
también estaba en el exilio ellas tres
junto a otros opositores algunos de
ellos están en el exilio otros están en
prisión buscan hacer contrapeso a
alexander lukachenko el presidente de
belarús considerado por varios
organismos internacionales como el
último dictador de europa por su larga
estancia en el poder y sobre todo por su
mano dura a la hora de gobernar de quién
se trata
alexander y bill lukashenko nació en
1954 es licenciado en historia sirvió en
el ejército rojo dirigió una granja
colectiva durante la época de la unión
soviética y es presidente de belarús
desde 1994 y ha mantenido el país con
una economía estatizada parcialmente
cerrada occidente y muy dependiente de
rusia que es su gran aliado
internacional
para analizar este tema está con
nosotros router ferrero ella es docente
de ciencia política y estudios europeos
de la universidad complutense de madrid
además es investigadora adscrita del
instituto de estudios internacionales se
une a esta conversación desde la ciudad
de madrid la capital de españa también
está con nosotros nicolás depedro él es
analista internacional jefe de
investigación del instituto forestal
craft en londres en el reino unido pero
se une a esta mesa de conversación desde
la ciudad de barcelona también en españa
y finalmente está con nosotros
pablo gonzález periodista y politólogo
especializado en europa del este- nos
acompaña desde la ciudad de varsovia la
capital de polonia también queremos
conocer todas sus opiniones y sus
preguntas pueden unirse a este debate a
través de las redes sociales france24 yo
en el piso unión bajo ese y mi cuenta
personal
santi logo puede dejar todos sus
comentarios con la etiqueta numeral el
debate efe 24 quiero comenzar por
nuestra invitada root ferreiro ferrero
en la ciudad de madre
preguntándole ya ha pasado un mes desde
los resultados de estos comicios
presidenciales en belarús que tanto
pueden aguantar los ciudadanos la
oposición y lukashenko en estos
enfrentamientos desde su perspectiva
ruth bueno los ciudadanos van a aguantar
lucas5 va a aguantar esto es una choque
de trenes entre entre dos fuerzas en lo
que se ha demostrado es que lukashenko
está muy bien posicionado el terreno que
que a pesar de estar presenciando unas
movilizaciones que son históricas y que
han puesto en su contra una parte
importante de la ciudadanía que no ha
reconocido su victoria de las últimas
elecciones y que cuestionan de manera
sistemática lo que él intenta es a echar
mano digamos de las fuerzas de orden
público y el ejército que todavía
algunos le son ángeles son afines es
verdad que fuera de la capital ha habido
algunas fuerzas orden público que
básicamente han
se han posicionado en la de la oposición
pero eso no sucede y las grandes
ciudades y ha intentado por todos los
medios internacionalizar un conflicto
involucrando y lo sigue intentando
involucrando la
a rusia así que bueno lo que es lo que
más llama la atención es la capacidad de
resistencia de las personas que están
movilizándose de manera infatigable en
las calles desde bielorrusia de belarús
desde desde el final del conteo del
proceso electoral y eso es algo que es
realmente inaudito en este en este país
es un tipo de afloje en ninguna de las
partes está dispuesta a ceder terreno
nicolás de pedro en la ciudad de
barcelona su opinión sobre este primer
mes de manifestaciones después de unas
elecciones señaladas de haber sido
fraudulentas por varios organismos
internacionales y por supuesto por la
oposición y algunos sectores de la
sociedad de belarús
bueno
básicamente como apuntaba luz ha sido
sorprende la capacidad de resistencia
mostrada por la ciudadanía de belarús
las manifestaciones han sido cada vez
más masivas más transversales de hecho
la primera reacción de represión
policial provocó que se ensanchará la
base de las manifestaciones y se
incorporará también en el sector de las
fábricas de las factorías públicas que
ha sido muy muy significativo y muy
simbólico y de momento todo da la
impresión de que la gente vaya a cejar
en su empeño de seguir manifestándose
semanalmente o sea que esto ha sido
francamente sorprendente también estamos
viendo en estos últimos días en un rol
muy importante que están jugando las
mujeres de toda clase y condición que
también es muy
muy llamativo
y veremos cuánto tiempo es posible que
consiguen mantener esta situación o si
finalmente consigue las fuerzas de
seguridad del régimen ya apoyadas por
operativos rusos quebrar esta esta
resistencia en las calles para cerrar
esta primera ronda con el balance de
este primer mes pablo gonzález en
varsovia un poco más cerca del terreno
polonia es un país que tiene frontera
con belarús y ha seguido muy de cerca
los hechos principalmente en minsk sus
impresiones de este primer mes
bueno este primer mes pues coincido con
ambos en las explicaciones anteriores
han demostrado por un lado la una una
resistencia o unas ganas de protesta
unas ganas de más que de protección a
las ganas de que nunca 5 se vaya de la
población mucho mayores de los que él
podría esperar ante todo sobre todo si
tenemos en cuenta que se ha proclamado
20 de las elecciones con un 80 por
ciento teórico de los de los votos
y por otro lado el propio lukashenko
también ha demostrado que no va a ser
tan sencillo que hacer que se vaya como
puede ser en otros lugares yo realmente
opinó que en estos casos seguramente el
tiempo fuera juega a favor de régimen es
decir se régimen consigue consigue
aguantar las primeras semanas los
primeros días luego las primeras semanas
al principio tuvimos unas
manifestaciones bastante importantes en
tratamientos con la policía luego un
intento de huelga general en varias
fábricas pararon durante 123 días pero
se ha reducido al que la gente sale solo
los domingos a veces los sábados salen
entre semana pero bastante menos siempre
a la actividad económica del país y
claro lukashenko aguanta
con esta perspectiva también sus fuerzas
policiales están poco a poco intentando
desmantelar la coordinación de la
oposición
del consejo coordinador de la oposición
a sólo 12 miembros que están dentro del
país que se llamaría calificaba y es
slam alexis el resto y maría cristina
está detenida el resto están todos
exiliados entonces claro y por un lado
se ha demostrado que lukashenko está
claro que no tiene yo apoyo del 80 por
ciento pero por otro lado se ha
demostrado también que lukashenko ha
preparado un estado policial
bastante resistente sobre todo si lo
comparamos no con casos como podría
haber sido ucraniano hace unos años en
el que la protesta social entre 22 donde
diferentes grupos hizo que el que el
presidente de mediado kovic tuviera
mucho más de pistas de lo que de lo que
lo que ya lo ha hecho o lukashenko que
no no sólo no ha huido sino que ha
salido con esta con esta imagen de
hombre 25 con una vez dijo vamos
totalmente fuera del lugar quiero hacer
una construcción con ustedes tres
aprovechando que obviamente conocen muy
bien los detalles de esta crisis que es
muy ajena para el público de américa
latina
cuáles son las particulares las
particularidades de esta crisis política
que vive belarús porque es distinta a la
crisis que vivió por ejemplo ucrania que
es un país vecino también parte de la de
la órbita de la antigua unión soviética
comienzo con pablo para hacer la ronda
en sentido contrario sus puntos
destacados sobre cuáles son las
particularidades
una de las particularidades de esta
crisis es que seguramente por un lado no
tengamos no tengamos un programa de la
oposición demasiado claro es decir si en
el tema ucraniano no era una
contraposición contraposición entre la
entrada en la teórica entrada o
acercamiento hacia la unión europea o el
teórico o acercamiento y entrada en la
unión aduanera promovida por rusia en
este caso
no hay una digamos hay una protesta
contra lukashenko pero incluso la gente
que está donde que está agrupada de la
oposición es decir sistemática nos queda
tiene una propuesta más o una visión más
occidental
mariah calificaba teóricamente junto
porque ella representa a la candidatura
de víctor y ccoo tiene una visión más
oriental no más vital hacia rusia no y
lo mismo pasa con los cercaron o los
matrimonios que también a priori tiene
una propuesta de más hacia rusia
entonces toda esta gente está en una
sola oposición pero con unas
es bastante diferentes y también el tema
nacional el tema nacionalista no de
contra por contraposición del idioma por
ejemplo o la nación de los usa se están
poniendo bastante menos en el caldero lo
que se hacía en ucrania no tampoco bueno
aunque ha habido algunas personas no
como el ex presidente ruso quedan que
han hablado de el tema del idioma pero
no es un no es algo que esté tampoco en
la agenda no no se supone que
bielorrusia debería elegir ahora mismo
si es ir hacia un lado hacer otro es más
bien yo creo que una una visión de vido
rusia que quiere de que quiere ser
diferente más democrática y poder elegir
libremente a sus candidatos y que se
ponga sin que se vaya a auto imponiendo
una persona que lleva en el poder desde
1994 claro entonces estas que pablo
quizás serían las claves para mí y luego
podríamos hablar ya de economía 10
cetera si nicolás su opinión porque es
diferente esta crisis del este de europa
a otras que hemos visto en
anteriores
bueno todos los contextos al final
tienen sus particularidades y son
distintas y efectivamente como comentaba
pablo gonzález esta es una crisis que
empieza con él
de forma endógena en lo que lo que une
tanto a las tres mujeres que representan
a la oposición como al grueso de la
gente que se manifiesta a las calles es
básicamente su hartazgo con el régimen
de lukashenko y esto es muy claro que
hay que hay este deseo de poner fin a
este régimen que tiene vocación de
perpetuarse de forma vitalicia e incluso
de ser sucedido por su hijo que tiene
ahora 15 años o sea que esto es
claramente lo que hay no tenía en ningún
caso en su gestación una connotación
claramente geopolítica como sí tuvo en
parte en la cuestión de ucrania y esto
le da un carácter más endógeno
claramente no introduce esta variable
ahora bien el papel que está jugando
rusia el hecho de que lukashenko haya
puesto ya su suerte su destino en manos
del kremlin y haya pedido ayuda
desesperada al kremlin introduce esta
variable porque evidentemente
a él un poco el resultado final depende
no exclusivamente pero si tiene un papel
importante o un peso importante lo que
decide hacer el kremlin con lukashenko
con con el conjunto del país y esto
habrá que verlo porque
por un lado los miembros de la oposición
no tienen
de hecho no tienen ninguna agenda que se
sepa prooccidental al contrario también
en buena medida son conocidos sus
vínculos con rusia incluyendo el marido
de tejano busca que ha hecho unas
declaraciones bueno en otro sentido
desde que está refugiada en lituania
pero las opiniones su marido
como bloguero eran otras hasta hace bien
poco ahora bien no un elemento de
incertidumbre para el kremlin y para
todos es qué impacto puede tener en
función de cómo se produzca esta
progresiva intervención rusa en belarús
seguimos va a ser aceptada tanto por la
población como por un segmento de las
fuerzas armadas esto es un estos son
elementos que no se puede saber porque
de la poca investigación sociológica
poco estudios de opinión porque belarús
es una dictadura y no las permite de lo
poco que se ha hecho en los últimos años
y hay disponible en principio lo que
dicen estos estudios es que
la población quiere mantener el estatus
que tiene actualmente o sea no desea ni
ser absorbida por rusia que es en parte
lo que el crimen parece que quiere a
medio y largo plazo ni tampoco
necesariamente incorporarse como miembro
llamar a la puerta de la unión europea
ni con o sea que quiere mantener su
soberanía entonces veremos este es un
factor incertidumbre esos puntos los
vamos a analizar en más adelante cierro
esta ronda con ruth sobre estas
particularidades queda claro que
entonces aquí no hay una intención de
alejarse de rusia y apostarle por el
plan que ofrece la unión europea o
entrar a la otan como es el caso de
ucrania o como fue en su momento georgia
aquí la agenda es completamente
diferente simplemente es una alternancia
en el poder una renovación de esa clase
política y del gobierno entonces
si básicamente estoy acá con mis
compañeros no hay discrepancias digamos
de alineación geopolítica aparentemente
en la agenda es verdad que no hay un
programa de gobierno pero lo que sí que
lo que sí que yo diría que se trata de
lo que pide la oposición de montar un
momento constituyente y un y generar un
nuevo contrato social en el marco en el
marco de bielorrusia sin generar cambios
de tipo geopolítico pero sigue cambiando
el régimen de derechos y libertades que
tienen hasta ahora y desde el año 94 los
vilos rusos y las bielorrusas es verdad
también que no hay no hay indicadores ni
ni ni ni cuál ni nada que nos pueda que
nos puede hacer
como tendencias pero atlantistas como se
han visto en otros territorios como
puede ser el caso ucraniano el caso
georgiano que mencionaba antes pero sí
que sí que es importante plantear o de
poner sobre la mesa lo que precisamente
quiere esa posición que es poner en
marcha ese nuevo proceso es un proceso
constituyente es el programa de cambio
hacia más democracia
manteniendo su independencia y su
autonomía de rusia creo recordar que
alguna encuesta que había había
circulando planteaba que en torno a de
más de 70 por ciento de la población
bielorrusa prefiere mantener ese estatus
y esto es un poco lo que está en juego
ver hasta qué hasta qué punto lukashenko
necesita a rusia para mantenerse en el
poder y a cambio de que va a vender
entre comillas alma al es y va a
ser a cambio de una integración con
rusia que es lo que persigue también no
sé me adelanté tanto ruth que ya o
analizar ese punto quiero quiero que
usted me explique y también armemos acá
entre todos estas tres mujeres muchos
pensaban que eran mujeres
que eran simplemente amas de casa madres
pero son personas que han estado
vinculadas al escenario político de
belarús ya por varios años siendo de la
oposición pero ustedes lo mencionan no
hay un plan cohesionado no hay una
articulación entre los diferentes
partidos de la oposición tiene entonces
futuro la oposición de belarús
con un mes ya en sus espaldas de
manifestaciones muchos de ellos en el
exilio de lograr este objetivo de hacer
una transición a otro gobernante que
mantenga esa política de independencia
estando digámoslo en la bisagra entre
unión europea y rusia-
bueno yo es que creo que no hay tal
equidistancia entre la unión europea y
rusia- por parte de la clase política
velo rusa hay una clara alineación con
rusia es el país es absolutamente
dependiente económica y comercialmente
de rusia del mercado ruso es mercado
cautivo el caso y que ha conseguido
mantener una en los niveles de bienestar
y de y de igualdad social que
desconocidos en otros en otros
territorios del espacio postsoviético y
eso solamente ha sido posible
precisamente por ese por esa dependencia
económica que se tiene desde bielorrusia
a rusia y por lo tanto no hay no hay ita
liq y distancia por otro lado sí que hay
presiones especialmente desde hace
aproximadamente un año año y medio que
se han ido recrudeciendo con las
recortes de determinados subsidios a la
economía bielorrusa y a la retirada
también de las ayudas a la exportación
de petróleo por parte de rusia
bielorrusia para forzar al
al presidente lukashenko de avanzar en
este proyecto de integración que fue
firmado vamos a recordar entre boris
yeltsin
y el propio lukashenko que en algún
momento pensó que podría llegar a ser
efectivamente cuando ha visto que esto
no operaba de esta forma ha preferido
ser cabeza de ratón que cola de león y
de hecho se ha mantenido en sus trece en
lo que hemos visto a nivel geopolítico
si es una aproximación precisamente para
intentar desapegarse de éstas depende
esta dependencia económica y comercial
de rusia hacia china y hacia eeuu y
hacia estados unidos intentando importar
gas licuado por ejemplo en lugar de ser
tan dependiente de tan dependiente de
rusia pero esto todavía es muy
incipiente y además ahora con esta
situación en la calle es algo que no que
no va a ser posible sostener por parte
de lukashenko nicolás quien sostiene a
lukashenko en el poder que es lo que lo
mantiene todavía allí por más de dos
décadas gobernando
a este país
bueno en este momento parece que
claramente la voluntad del kremlin
también
el estado policial que de momento parece
que resiste la presión pero él ha puesto
y es muy significativo no hasta las
elecciones para qué
recordamos que la audiencia hasta las
elecciones del 9 de agosto lukashenka
básicamente acusaba a este trío a medida
que vio que este trío de mujeres que un
poco están ahí en cabeza de esta de este
movimiento oposición por
circunstancialmente porque sus
respectivos parejas o en el caso de
mujeres de jefes y exacto el caso de la
franja para la campaña de víctor
barbárica en este él empieza a acusarles
a este movimiento de tener precisamente
estar agitando lo de ser agitado
instrumentalizado por por el kremlin
recordemos hay un oscuro incidente con
unos contratistas de wagner los
paramilitares unos mercenarios rusos que
crecen por allá y es el régimen en ese
momento los acusa de formar parte de una
operación orquestada por la oposición y
rusia para deponer menos
una vez que pasan las elecciones y
cuando se produce la primera semana y
lukashenko probablemente se ve muy una
extracción muy débil
y capaz de contener lo que está viendo y
cuando llama al kremlin que tiene varias
llamadas y finalmente la última llamada
para tener pues que putin le da le
muestro cierto apoyo y el kremlin emite
un comunicado mostrando su apoyo a
belarús aunque no menciona
explícitamente la figura de lucas y
entonces la narrativa ha ido cambiando
entonces haya cambiado tanto la
narrativa de los medios rusos como la
propia narrativa del régimen o bien
todos dan a entender que la oposición
está manipulada o tiene viene desde
fuera y demás no entonces
lukashenko desde ese momento desde el 16
15 16 de agosto claramente ha puesto su
destino
en manos del kremlin pero él yo creo que
es es una estación de esperada para el
de debilidad pero es consciente de que
el kremlin a medio plazo incluso a corto
plazo podría incluso optar por un
reemplazo esto es un escenario muy
fiable que le deja en una posición muy
débil aunque una posición muy débil de
lukashenko y además con un look a sin
que haya muy aislado de occidente porque
también para que lo tenga que la
audiencia
irritando al kremlin con lukashenko es
que en los últimos años en parte o en
buena medida a la luz de lo sucedido en
georgia la intervención militar usa a
georgia y después la anexión de crimea e
intervención militar encubierta un
máster de ucrania en el donbass
exactamente en lo que ha intentado es
tratar de reforzar su relación y tener
ciertos lazos económicos como comentaba
anteriormente lucero de eeuu chiná y
unión europea y abrir también
prácticamente un descongelamiento con
occidente y esto es lo que ha ido en
tour viendo su relación con moscú
precisamente sobre esa relación con
occidente le quería preguntar a pablo
otro de nuestros invitados aquí que qué
papel tiene en eeuu y la unión europea
obviamente tanto rusia como belarús han
acusado a estados unidos de estar
interviniendo de estar fomentando esta
inestabilidad y estas marchas que han
tenido lugar en minsk la capital qué
papel tienen estos dos actores
internacionales allí
bueno eeuu realmente está ahora un poco
ausente de esta crisis porque pues bueno
tiene sus propios sus propios problemas
actualmente aunque recordemos que este
año ha visitado para irritación del
kremlin ha visitado min
el secretario de estado con algo que
decir no sentó nada bien y dice lin
porque realmente como como bien dice el
señor dicas de pedro
este juego de lukashenko de intentar
vivir de la subvención a las elecciones
rusas no porque recordamos que una de
las claves no es tanto el mercado ruso
sino es que dentro de la unión aduanera
la unión económica una especie de unión
europea entre los dos países pero rusia
gozaba y sigue gozando aunque en menor
medida de precios sobre todo para
productos energéticos como gas y
petróleo de precios de interiores de
rusia que son precios bastante menores a
los precios de mercado internacional
entonces rusia básicamente compraba
en rusia el petróleo y los exportaba una
vez elaborado en sus refinerías siendo
esto un 320 un 25 30 depende del año el
porcentaje del pib bielorruso es decir
este doping económico que le
proporcionaba a rusia rusia quería un
poco a poco según se iban a enfriando
sus relaciones con occidente
y se iban se iba caldeando como como se
ha apuntado no primero a la raíz de
georgia no cuando rusia reconoció a
osetia y abjasia y vino al buque nuevo
que no hizo minsk y después claro por
ejemplo sobre todo con crime and o en el
momento en que vio rusia se desentiende
de este tema y no quiere reconocer que
línea como como rusa pues estos pecados
se intimidan relaciones y en este
momento lukashenko intenta abrirse hacia
hacia occidente sobre todo pues con
éstos
que no sólo occidente también a china
por ejemplo
con quien ha intentado entablar unas
relaciones económicas con algo con algo
de éxito pero sin llegar a unas
cantidades realmente importantes
y entonces sí con eeuu obteniendo estos
pequeños contactos que realmente si
cogemos lo del gas licuado es son
cantidades ínfimas más simbólicas sobre
todo porque la economía bielorrusa no
sólo puede nos lo puede permitir y con
la unión europea a la unión europea está
denuncia forma parte del signo del
programa de la es uno de los países que
están dentro del programa del siglo para
los países de europa del este y el
cáucaso pero pero día a día de hoy
[Música]
quedan pocos minutos para cerrar el
programa ime y tengo todavía temas
pendientes en nicolás quería que
habláramos de la relación que tiene con
rusia
lukashenko después de haberle pedido
ayuda para mantenerse en el poder y
hacer frente a esta crisis es este el
escenario en el que rusia puede
aprovechar y desarrollar ese plan del
estado de la unión para anexar a belarús
a su territorio
solamente por la ayuda que lukashenko
necesita desesperadamente para
mantenerse en el poder
si este claramente es una de las
posibilidades no uno de los escenarios
en el comunicado que emitió el kremlin
el 16 de agosto y hacía mención a estos
momentos de creencia así vamos a apoyar
a belarús en el marco de este estado de
la unión y también si es necesario con
la utilización o el empleo de la
relación del tratado de seguridad
colectiva es decir por un lado se pone
el precio político el estado de la unión
que es de facto acabará en una absorción
de belarús y se lleva si se lleva a cabo
y se introduce en el elemento militar
para garantizar que que eventualmente se
puede utilizar este instrumento para
imponerlo entonces
como comentaba antes no un lukashenka
débil claramente para moscú es un
es un escenario favorable para favorable
y propicio para avanzar en esta línea
porque completamente débil y aislado y
completamente aislado también de
occidente pues esto le deja en una
situación que vemos claramente puede
puede aprovechar ahora bien como es una
posición tan débil y visto es un nivel
altísimo nivel de impopularidad entre la
población de larousse no es descartable
que moscú busquen también y reemplazarlo
porque esto tampoco es un escenario
impensable y que busca algún tipo de
solución que permita también aplacar un
poco está esta voluntad popular así que
es un escenario abierto pero favorable y
propicio para los planes del kremlin y
en el escenario mucho más caótico
podemos decirlo así ese nuevo estado de
la unión ese organismo supranacional
podría despertarle a putin también
deseos de ser también presidente o
mandatario es escenario de ese posible
organismo supranacional eso significaría
que podría estar más tiempo en el poder
y hacer un escenario también válido dado
el caso me quedan cuatro minutos para
hacer las conclusiones el root que cree
usted que va a pasar en este país del
este de europa como ve usted el
escenario al futuro
bueno yo creo que tenemos que esperar a
un medio plazo no al corto plazo hay que
ver cómo se van desarrollando los
acontecimientos no no es sencillo
predecir qué es lo que puede suceder lo
que sí que es verdad es que bielorrusia
o belarús es uno de los pocos países que
no ha puesto en marcha un proceso de
cambio político y económico dentro de
los territorios del espacio ex soviético
es también cierto que es muy dependiente
de rusia tanto en lo económico como en
lo militar y en el tema de defensa
seguridad defensa y también que como
decía
[Música]
nicolás de pedro en la situación la
situación de anexión puede darse en
cualquier momento
tenemos que tener en cuenta que quizás
una maniobra de maldad a un paso mandado
por parte de la luz se podría revertir
digamos la opinión pública favorable a
las alianza con moscú nicolás a su
conclusión como el escenario a futuro
route dice que a mediano plazo no
podemos estar mirando a corto plazo la
situación que se está presentando allí
bueno el escenario está abierto y es
incierto porque no podemos decir sin
lukashenko resistirá o no dependerá un
poco de la voluntad del kremlin de que
quiera hacer con él
los deseos del premio están claros pero
también hay yo creo dos grandes
incógnitas cuál va a ser la reacción de
la ciudadanía de belarús porque si la
anexión es muy evidente o se produce de
tal forma o si se decide por mantener a
lukashenko contra esta voluntad popular
bueno pues esto puede generar una
reacción y cambiar el escenario y acabar
pasando como como en ucrania que la
intervención rusa acabe fortaleciendo
una identidad política en nítidamente
ucraniana donde hasta entonces quizás no
no lo era tan no lo era tanto y luego
hay otro factor un segundo factor de
incertidumbre muy breve que es parte de
las fuerzas armadas bielorrusas que
aunque en la práctica tiene una
dependencia y están en buena medida
estructuradas dentro del entramado de la
estructura militar rusa
veremos si aceptan con total sumisión si
estos planes se llevan adelante yo creo
que es también otro factor de
incertidumbre a seguir de cerca y pablo
para el cierre su conclusión me quedan
40 segundos
y yo comparto las conclusiones que he
dicho ha dicho road vamos a mirar desde
luego a corto plazo seguramente la
ocasión por exista pero vamos a ver qué
es lo que sucede a medio plazo con las
voluntades de moscú con los los apoyos
que están dando los países bálticos a
polonia de la oposición y entonces bueno
es un escenario abierto que veremos pero
desde luego lo que sí que está en juego
es la independencia de vídeo rusia como
como estado pues a mis tres invitados
muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros ahí tienen ustedes sus
opiniones las conclusiones pues también
las pueden sacar ustedes en sus hogares
por favor deje todos sus comentarios a
través de las redes sociales siga con
nuestra programación
[Música]